je vous lisais en titre fini les
clôtures abusives qui dénaturaient les
paysages de Sologne sur près de 4000 km
et fragilisait la biodiversité la
proposition de loi limitant
l'embrayagement a été adopté à
l'Assemblée la semaine dernière par
l'ensemble des députés un bras de fer
entre les propriétaires fortunés et les
associations écologistes qui duraient
depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années
Florent Clavel
c'est clôtures pourrait être les
premières victimes de la loi de Cardou
Ramos trop haute
hérissée de barbelés et enterré un
animal n'a aucune chance de passer
Sébastien Camus est le régisseur de ce
domaine de 70 hectares situés à yvoye le
marron c'est clôtures ce n'est pas lui
mais sont riches voisins qui les a posés
les voir tomber seraient une victoire
pour ce solognion en lutte contre
l'engriègement depuis des années c'est
plutôt historique parce que ça fait des
dizaines d'années que on se bat contre
cet engriècement abusif et à l'heure
aujourd'hui du dérèglement climatique et
d'extinction de masse de certaines
espèces il t'étendent se poser des
questions et puis d'agir
adopter la semaine dernière en première
lecture par l'Assemblée nationale la loi
Cardou Ramos s'impose trois critères des
clôtures posées 30 cm au-dessus du sol
haute d'un mètre 20 maximum et qui ne
peuvent ni blesser ni piéger la faune en
outre elle est rétroactive sur 30 ans ça
veut dire que si vous avez un grillage
qui est enterré qui est qui a plus d'un
mètre 20 et ben même si jusqu'à 30 ans
en arrière il va falloir l'enlever et
vous allez pouvoir laisser passer la
faune la faune sauvage que ça soit même
débat tracée en dessous à 30 cm et puis
les chevreuils les serres les biches qui
pourront passer librement au-dessus à un
mètre 20 une loi soutenue à la fois par
les amoureux de la nature mais aussi les
chasseurs lassés de ces enclos ou de
grands propriétaires pratiquent une
chasse souvent qualifiée de balle
trappes vivants un message reçu par le
gouvernement qui promet une application
rapide du texte